Donald Trump has chimed in and said this
is the kiss of death for Ronda santis
and uh this you know look Ashley stclair
I'm I'm look let me slow down you know
how we have these really awesome quotes
from the founding fathers and you you'll
like look in a book and you'll be like
reading about some crazy dude in the
16th century and he'll say something
like th the king hereby declareth
through Divine Providence means as much
Declarations of Divine Providence mean
as much to me as the manure of a horse
and you're like wow like look how bold
now it's like that was because when they
wrote things down it was rare they
talked a lot of smack but they rarely
wrote things down so when they did they
really thought them through mhm now
you're going to have quotes from people
in the history books that just like like
I got some quotes for you man like if
you go through my Twitter and pull up
some of the quotes people are going to
be like what like you know like posting
pictures like someone's going to like I
posted a picture of a hairless rabbit
once for no reason yeah and it's like
you couldn't imagine the finding fathers
doing I mean you could they would be
silly sometimes like Ben Franklin was
known to be to have a sense of humor but
so now we're looking at the story about
Ronda sandis and his and his and his
high heels of course he is absolutely I
think it's proven at this point Beyond a
reasonable doubt he's wearing high
he's been convicted in Shoe Court in
public court well because there's that
video where he's walking and and it it
you know his foot doesn't exist it folds
straight I saw the interview off the
rack yes and and who says that my point
is this the history books are going to
are going to say what I don't know what
date was but like you know in in October
of 2023 Ashley stclair posted a video
making fun of the Rhonda Sanders
campaign and putting on thigh high
cowboy boots the which which generated a
response from from Ronda sanz's PR team
this led to a larger conversation on the
Tim cast podcast finally a statement
from the president from the from the
front runner for the Republican party on
his his rival wearing high heeled boots
this is what the history books are going
to say live in such an unserious time
it's unbelievable it is unserious in a
sense yeah it feels like a sitcom
episode where like he's going around and
they're like you're wearing high heels
like they're not heels they're lips and
he has to keep correcting it's a
dystopian dark comedy though I'm okay
with it though why didn't they stuff his
boots like look at this
picture like guys take some toy they're
even too long not only are they too high
they're too long what what is this so
just pick them up with
a too long because his foot's pulled
back on
a so so and then a lot of people are
pointing out when he said uh they're off
the rack liesi boots people are like who
says off the rack no he he hadn't seen
like oh I haven't seen this I'm like
you've seen this bro don't anyway anyway
the point is the point is Donald Trump
chiming in and uh do we have the uh I
think the post millennial had let let me
let me pull up the post Millennials
version because they I think they
actually have the statement from Donald
Trump I guess The Daily Beast didn't
have the statement they just mentioned
that Donald Trump chimed in I don't know
whatever let me see I think uh what do
we got here we go Trump campaign respond
to boot gate calls it the kiss of death
Kellen is claiming boot gate is his Kell
bootate Kellen is claiming that that's
his term that he came up with of a
scathing new article from Politico about
Ron D santimon say high heeled shoes
comes on the heels of an embarrassing
interview on the Patrick Bet David show
that led to boot gate trending on X when
asked directly about why his boots look
like stilts the sanctis offered up the
implausible explanation that he just
wears off the rack liesi boots doing
major brand damage to a great American
footwear company oh yeah some brand
damage all right this is why Trump wins
against the santis at least because
that's the kind of funny statement like
a side joke where it's like you accuse s
of of of bmer merching the good name of
lucazi he says if there is any
enterprising journalist willing to
contact the lucazi Press team for their
thoughts on desanctis they're reachable
here and then he link to it in another
moment of insanity Rond offer up the
laughable claim that he's 5'11 instead
of telling the truth truth and just
being comfortable in his own skin he
resorts to borderline psychotic behavior
by lying to the American people is that
what this country wants an a president
Okay blah blah this is not from this is
It's Stephen Chong Trump spokesperson
but I just want to say I think Ronda
santis is the dumbest politician I've
seen in my life the dumbest um look
policy-wise did some good stuff I'm now
going to chalk it up to the Florida
State Legislature a large body of
individuals pushed forth a bunch of
ideas and Ron said okay sounds good and
he's getting all the credit for it Ron
has got to be the dumbest guy in
politics because he's had every
opportunity after every single blunder
and failure he won't fire these guys he
won't fire his PR team it's almost like
he's doing it on purpose maybe Ron's the
smartest guy in politics and I can't
understand why it is he would destroy
himself in this way or he's just really
really dumb he's dumb but let's let's
talk about how unfortunate it is that
our political discourse as as and I
don't want to come off as the pendant
and the uh former Professor etc etc but
look at the depth to which our discourse
has sunk if we can't win in the realm of
ideas we have to resort to Boots and
boot gate boot gate it was look it's
Halloween this was the trending story
this morning when I wake up I'm like are
you kidding me it's like a 100,000
tweets boot gate boots Trump it's
accessible to everyone it is kind of
what has turned politics into a bit of a
spectator team sport which team sport I
I admit that it's is it necessarily the
greatest thing for America for America
as a whole no but I have a lot of fun
with it doesn't bother me fun it's fun I
wish it was like a cartoon instead of
reality but I was uh recently recently
Gren Glenn Greenwald was on uh Jordan
Peterson's podcast and one of the things
that they were talking about was people
today with the with the kind of the the
fact that religion became less important
in communities and less important to
Americans people replaced religion with
essentially what boils down to State
worship it's not quite that but but
that's that's essentially the effect um
and I think that's probably the biggest
problem that we have in the US now I'm
I'm an agnostic I don't particularly
have a religion that I you know that I
I'm I'm more uh more you know more
likely to to be supportive of or
whatever but I don't think that we have
the option to not have a religion people
there's a lot of people that get it in
their head that humans should just
evolve past religion and they just don't
have any idea that they don't have any
idea how Evolution works if that's what
they think because it takes an outside
force for there to be Evolution religion
is ubiquitous across Humanity whether no
matter what Society you you you look at
every society no matter how far they are
apart in distance or in time every
society that that has had human has been
created by human beings has had some
kind of religion with it religion is as
Inseparable from H from The Human
Experience and from Psychology from
Human psychology as I think as humor or
as any other interpersonal relationship
it's probably a psychological phenomenon
built to deal with our own to deal with
having the motivation to Keep Us Alive
and at the same time Con well no at the
same time dealing with the fact that we
are finite and going to die real quick I
was thinking a lot about this earlier
and I was thinking about uh Kirk Cain
and I was thinking about um who was I
thinking about just a bunch of musicians
who who've killed themselves and I was
just like how is it that someone like
kurk Cain okay maybe it's not a good
example because there's conspiracy
theories around whether or not he
actually killed himself but there are
many uh rock stars mhm who uh you know
what I was thinking about I was thinking
of Matthew Perry and uh uh he's found
underwater in his hot tub drowning
Cardiac Arrest depends on the reports
and a lot of people said look man this
is a guy who did a lot of drugs in his
day and was like pretty messed up and
depressed for a while right is that just
yeah and also hot tub when with any
heart condition is a nogo not a good
idea so so I started thinking this like
how could you be on the show Friends the
biggest show and like still one of the
biggest shows ever mhm making how much
were they making per episode was like a
million bucks more than like yeah
several million dollars and then resort
to doing drugs I'm like how do you
that's the norm but no but no no no but
but I I think I get it how come Elon
Musk is the world's richest man and is
not doing drugs and not drinking purpose
and exactly MH so for for if you're a
regular dude and you're funny and then
someone says would you like to be funny
in my show and you're like sure and
every day you struggle every day you're
trying to figure out how to pay the
bills every day you're waking up figure
out how you're going to pay your rent
and then one day someone says make this
joke on TV you do boom biggest show in
the world all of a sudden you have no
struggle all of a sudden you are loaded
with cash you have nothing to do you
don't have to worry for anything and
you've never you've never had a strong
purpose your purpose has always been to
survive but now you don't have to
whereas Elon musk's purpose is Advance
Humanity in the ways he wants to so
what's what what's missing I believe and
always it just Roots down to one simple
thing for many people religion yeah yeah
and I think uh I think the point was
made that you know statism has become a
religion and and this was the case and
identity Poli that's how they they fight
the depression right there you've got
these young women that are chock full of
crazy pills you know the most irritating
thing to me is when I hear like some
Millennial woman be like he needs a
Xanax or like I take a no stop doing
these things well look I'm not going to
tell you what to do your doctor
prescribes it you do doctor says but I'm
just like it's insane that people are
like well better take a mood stabilizer
when they tell everybody else to get
therapy not realizing that it's not
necessarily for everybody it's we've
medicalized a lot of the world today to
act to your point with actors I think a
lot of it also has to do with the fact
that they have a a very dangerous
combination of both insanely High Egos
and extremely uh sensitive personalities
because uh the profession as a whole
requires you to be very much vulnerable
all the time which leads to heavy drug
use for a lot of them and I think that's
true of a lot of what's going on in
American culture right now is there's a
lot of uh there's a lot of depression
there's a lot of sadness and people it
could be that they're not filling it
with religion like they did in the past
and the people that are filling it with
what we would call now identity politics
or the state as a religion are being fed
uh an ideal an ideological means of
hatred and Stat failed religion EST
statism is a failed religion it will not
sustain you like if you want if we're
talking about marxists telling you
whoever told you you've been raised to
hate your country you've been raised to
hate people that are that see the world
differently than you while being told
that they're oppressing you even though
that dude's as poor that that dude is as
poor and as and as miserable as you are
how is that not a world of depression
and sadness for people and he gives you
a sense of moral superiority D allows
you it allows you to to oppress people
to act violently the whole punch a Nazi
thing it's like as soon as as soon as as
soon as the argument was it's acceptable
to punch a Nazi everybody became a Nazi
because it was just whoever I want to
punch as a Nazi that's the excuse the
your so it gives people the excuse to
behave terribly to behave with
aggression and and and Malice towards
other people and feel like they are they
are doing the morally correct thing and
that's I forget who it was but someone
someone quoted that that's the most
delicious of psychological treats to be
able to abuse someone and feel like
you're doing it as a good thing and if
you look at the the jihadis the the the
Islamic terrorists that's what they all
do they all believe that they're the
they are in the right and if they beat
the crap out of an Infidel God wanted
them to so that was a moral thing
throwing gay people off a building it
doesn't matter because God wanted it you
can be as atrocious to people that don't
believe in your religion as you want
because God has said it and it's the
same type of attitude from the marxists
in the farle when they're saying oh well
beat the Nazis another thing about
wokeness as a religion it's it's you
know unlike Christianity There's No
Redemption under worldless right so if
you're white and you know male you're
you're you're damned for for eternity
there's no way out and uh you know going
back to your point about religion uh
anthropologists have suggested you know
why religion is so um durable is because
it actually came at the same time as
civilization as we got into uh creation
and you know creativity Innovation Etc
it it sprouted at the exact same moment
so it's no surprise that it's it's so uh
it's so recalcitrant for some or
otherwise you might say it's very uh
it's it's a you know a kind of permanent
part of the human uh life and I'm
agnostic as well but imagine the hubris
of like just now in this time period
feeling like you found the answer that
every generation in the past didn't need
the the the the atheist movement in the
early 2010s probably did more damage to
America than it's it's it's exhausting I
I do love these like 18-year-old
leftists who think they've discovered
universal truth that no one else has
ever has ever thought of and like they
just have not read yeah any philosophers
yeah I was 184 once too I think a lot of
it is like in the age of the internet
like the the ease of access to
information and this is something that I
think we're all at least somebody like
me is guilty of as well and have to like
put myself in check like knowing
something isn't the same thing as
understanding it like and you have
access to a lot of information and then
you have people believing that they know
better than somebody who's practical in
their field and that's just not the way
the world works right yeah you have to
actually live things and experience
things to have real knowledge it isn't
something you can impart through just
information per se yeah um
yeah I don't know it's uh all of it is
very like that is the most depressing
like out of all the conversations we
just had that might be the most
depressing like all the war and
everything but it's like everything
that's going on I find like what's gone
on in the last cuz it's like it's been
so quick in the last 12 to 15 years the
the shift in American values in the last
15 years has been so abrupt but why is
that shift happening because Millennials
are entering the
workforce so it was a crazy moment for
me when I used to play shows as a
teenager I'd go to a cafe and I'd play
an open mic and then one day I turned 21
and when I used to play shows as a
teenager everyone at the shows was
always between the ages of like 16 and
20 CU as soon as you turn 21 you're at
the bars so I turned 21 and I'm like I'm
going to find an open mic and I'm like
oh here's one I'm like I'd go to open
mic.com and I'm like oh it's at a bar I
show up everyone's 40 and I was like
whoa this is kind of weird like I've
never experienced this all of a sudden
it was like the training wheels come off
and welcome to the real world the entire
bar is full of people of all different
there's like several decades here of
different values different worldviews I
had now at that point entered that this
adult space for the first time playing
shows with people with tremendous way
more experience way more opinion more
knowledge more wisdom some stupid people
don't get me wrong and so what happens
is we're like how did it how did the how
did how this country changing it's not
that people are becoming woke it's that
young people were indoctrinated to be
woke and now they're old enough to have
an influence in the marketplace yeah in
politics there's a white pill I'd like
to drop on all this is I think I I do
think there's going to be a renaissance
of uh liberty-minded people that's going
to come out of this movement uh because
the as you pointed out it's a path to
you know destruction destitution uh
economically socially it leads to you
know uh decadence and and uh there's
going to be a renaissance of L of of
liberty-minded people coming out of this
woke contagion I hope that's true but
I'm going to be honest like when I the
the number one place where I see this
topic is when people talk about the
housing market when they talk about the
price of housing how so many young
people are being PR you know the your
parents say go to college you're like oh
you went to college in a part-time job
blah blah blah we see these these very
very Doomer descriptions that are
accurate they're accurate to the world
we're living in right now but I don't
think that creates people who want free
markets because they've been poisoned to
believe that the free market is is a is
a is a yeah but I think we're going to
it's going to create Communists and it's
going to create socialist yeah but
they're going to they're going to
experience the misery that that brings
and that's we're all going to experience
we all and we're going to have to fight
our way out we have to fight our way out
we get that before we get to before we
get back to Liber it's going to be San
Francisco time 10 everywhere that's
depressing unless I'm not I'm not I'm
not convinced that it gets to a
communist Soviet style not exactly no I
think I think we may already be out of
the Tail Spin and starting to pull back
if you look at budlight sponsoring UFC
we all kind of groaned when they did but
now you see SE Sean Strickland being
like Oh yeah let's see how budlight
responds this dude getting up on stage
with a bud lighten hand saying a whole
bunch of anti-woke and offensive things
to make the point budlight is forced to
back him now and back his speech and his
speech is not favorable towards trans
people even if the tide is turning and
you might be right about the tide
turning even if it is this is something
that is going to take a while to get out
of the schools because there are people
that are going to fight like hell and
there's also industry that's already
built in you've got people with tenure
that aren't going to want to give up
their jobs you've got you've got schools
as long as they're in schools and
they're teaching kids these things kids
are be coming out of schools and you
have 20 years of of graduating classes
that believe this crap but I but what
I'm saying is two things first we we
we've part of the movement has already
been to criticize schools in general for
everything they are not just be like oh
there's winess in schools no it's not
right like schools are bad homeschool
your kids exactly but then also if young
if if if you go on Twitter if you go on
X if you go on Instagram you go on these
platforms and you have the wrong opinion
you're made fun of you don't get
followers if the shift among prominent
popular people and celebrities is
against the wokeness now especially
because of Israel yes these young look
I've told this story before when I went
to VidCon in like 2016 and uh I'm
walking as I'm walking in I see these
group of kids probably 13 years old and
one kid goes you have 80 followers how
do you have 80 followers wow and like
these little kids are growing up in a
world where follower count matters and
that's going to warp their brains in
crazy ways but guess what if you're in
high school and you're like I want a
million followers and then you see all
the celebrities are getting behind
Israel and opposing the left right and
now you get Amy Schumer retweeting or
posting on Instagram campus reform which
is a more right leaning Outlet now these
young people are like I want a million
followers I want to be a celebrity and
they're going to go in this dire that's
right I think I've said this in my book
great reset and a struggle for Liberty
we need defection from the elites we're
always going to have Elites there's a
natural Elites you know not just those
that are propped up by the state and
other artificial measures but we need
defectors and you know perhaps Elon Musk
is want we need other defectors from the
elite and yes you could be right and
pull you know so give people somebody to
you know we need public voices that that
come out against all this and that will
be a big part of this and I hope to make
my campaign part of that and that is to
you know be publicly stating these
things undoing the Mind virus is there
like a primary for the libertarian yeah
there is a primary when is it it's
ongoing now oh it's ongo now oh yeah it
goes well see we we have a convention in
May and that convention that's where the
candidate is chosen by delegates
delegates yes it's not an open voting
system it's a delegate selection system
sound very
libertarian I know no that what you mean
to say is that doesn't sound Democratic
but um libertarianism and democracy are
kind of there's a tension there let's be
real about that yeah yeah because
actually democracy in in in its extremes
it infringes property rights 100% okay
so you know three out of four say your
your your money is mine U you know there
you go you can rob that guy so but kind
system but I do kind of feel like you
know just start from the ground if if
you are a Libertarian the question is
why does anyone have authority over me
right good question and nobody as
Libertarians we don't think you should
have authority over here so why am I
running for office is that where you're
going no why why is it a delegate based
system that's determining who gets to be
the nominee why why why does the party
have the authority over over my choice
in who should be the nominee who should
be uh yeah yeah I mean to be to be fair
it's because the party is giving them
the backing basically yes that's right
so so the party is choosing at least
it's honest about it look at the
Democratic party what they're going to
do right what well what they were going
to do to Kennedy for example and they
made it very clear it didn't matter how
how many votes he got they were going to
give it to uh to Biden or whoever think
Biden whoever they stand up Biden needs
to be the nominee I don't think he will
be though whoever they stand up yeah if
they can stand him up you know long
enough to uh Gavin Gavin Nome met met
with Xin ping because he knows he sees
the running on the wall same as
everybody else it's not going to be
Biden feels like Gavin Nome like the
more the more that I see about it yeah
there's there's a lot of play out there
even when you see conservative women
being like I hate his guts but guy's
handsome you're just like man this like
he definitely has like an an evil
quality about him take a look around Los
Angeles take a look around San Francisco
look at the
outrageous uh just destitution and
horror that this this guy's policies
have brought to this to this state we've
talked about how the way to remove Joe
Biden is like the perfect scenario for
the Deep state is Joe Biden suffer some
kind of medical issue Gavin Newsome runs
on Biden's at a a rally in California
and then has grips his chest and then
Gavin Nome Runs Out perform CPR saves
the life of the president KLA Harris
steps in as acting president but says
she she does not want to start a
campaign this late in the season she
wants to do her duty to this country
Gavin Nome then says I will do it goes
on every also in the Press store but
what if what if it's just something
crazy like Joe Biden sacrifices himself
in some really crazy way like bringing
peace to the Middle East or whatever he
personally goes there and like walks on
the battlefield and holds up his hands
and then they're like no Joe and then he
goes on in history as like the Savior
that's how they get rid of him yeah I'd
be I'd be very surprised about that he's
going to eat an ice cream cone too fast
and die of a of a brain freeze uh
sniffing someone's hair by the edge of a
mountain and he just Falls right now
this guy's just a a prop I mean he's a
ventriloquist dummy there's nothing
there also to your point fil you know
but but I think it's fair to say more of
like um I don't know if ventriloquist
dummy is the right right phrase because
he's also sort of this vacuous pit for
moneya laundering yeah that's true you
know yeah yes that's that's true he has
kind of a money pocket in his u in his
puppetry maybe he's a Pneumatic banking
tube where where the government can put
the money and then it yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's true good point to to what
you were saying Phil also about the you
were mentioning the schools but also the
companies the corporations where all of
these policies have been enacted and are
now enshrined it's going to take an
inordinate amount of time to get that
removed from their what they call
mission statements or their company
values which is I still maybe more funny
than anything else is the idea that a
corporation has like a mission statement
or has values but you know you've got
you've got mid-level uh mid-level
employees with hiring capabilities that
have been indoctrinated with these
viewpoints who have been shoveled this
stuff for the last two decades you're
not just going to have to get rid of
them you're going to have to get rid of
the the people under them under them I
don't think there's a lot of conflict
between my point in what Tim says I'm
just talking I'm thinking that it's just
gonna take time to actually get this
stuff out it didn't happen overnight it
happened quickly because of the internet
and stuff but it didn't happen overnight
I don't know if it said it happened
quickly it's that they they plac the
chess pieces over a long period of time
that too and then and then the internet
just allowed the game to move faster
there there's something else in involved
with wokeness is it's not just cultural
or ideological it is actually economic
and they're actually they've seized upon
this as a means for establishing what I
call a woke cartel and that is to get
rid of businesses by of saying look if
you don't get Larry thinkink says Larry
thinkink of black Brock you don't if you
don't live up to this ESG now he's
changed the name of it cuz it's got such
a bad name if you don't live up to this
ESG we're not going to invest capital in
you so this is kind of a cartel scheme
on top of all the cultural stuff uh
wokeness is kind of like a a demarcation
device to to siphon Capital uh to the
right players and get rid of the rest
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net